[Music]
I'm pumped and I don't know why that
just got me in the mood I had the best
as a kid I grew up and my dad's like
best friends were had always had these
great Christmas Eve parties like this
Italian family and I used to go over and
they used to so many gifts like they had
someone dress up a Santa they like they
were giving me gifts like 20 30 people I
I knew them for my entire life the
Lombardo they're like where are they now
they're uh they still they still some of
them were with my dad in Florida most of
them still live on the east coast but
now the kids who were my age are taking
over the family business so it's pretty
cool what's the family business Lombardo
they have uh food yeah they it used to
be a grocery store but now they have
like a um a banquet hall and like a
nightclub where my that's where my dad
met the guy so it's just I was always
jealous of Christmas as a Jewish kid cuz
Hanukkah is not I mean it's okay there's
more nights but it's not you don't get
presents like Christmas no you do you
still get presents um but it's not the
first time I ever experienced Christmas
day my my cousin married a Christian
girl and uh I went and and stayed over
when the kids were like young maybe five
and three or something like that and how
old were
you maybe ear high school maybe maybe
just going into High School somewhere
around there no cuz I that was one of
the first times I drank so probably like
late High School um and Christmas
morning I never seen anything like it
they had so many toys and they were so
excited that they fell asleep under the
tree they were just so happy they were
just like they fell and they still a toy
St rap and I've always just Christmas is
see it seems like the best like there's
Jewish people now who are doing Hanukkah
bushes so they can have like a Hanukkah
tree and my mom hates it my mom nothing
pisses her off more than like a fake
Hanukkah bush cuz it's it's there's it's
not real but it's like it's just you
know some people's
Traditions or or the culture like for
example you went to school and the kids
are talking about Christmas you're like
what the [__] are they talking about so
you want to americanize them in a way
and you get a Hanukkah Bullit and I know
where your mom's coming from I'm the
same [__] way a stickler about that
[__] but these kids are Americanized you
have to americanize them can you imagine
going to school and you don't get
[__] gifts well kids who don't don't
the Jehovah Witnesses they don't
celebrate Christmas either they don't
anything so those [__] kids got to go
to school next week and everybody's got
new t-shirts on and [__] and these kids
still got their same muggy [__]
clothes on feeling like you know
I never understood that I never [__]
understood that religion is religion and
children are children religion is
religion and children are [__]
children you know nothing count you know
really really really you're not going to
give gifts cuz you're a [__] Jehovah
Witness and you're a knucklehead that
wants to knock on people's doors and
[__] bother them no other religion
bothers you at your [__] door no
other [__] religion bothers you these
people come to your [__] door when
you least expect it you're like just
sitting there going wow this sandwich is
great don't say he a knock and you're
like you know what maybe I won't get it
and you're like no let me go get it and
you open the door and you see him with
their three little [__] dudes with a
chick at the bottom floor and they got
their little brown case like they're
going to discuss business with you like
they Trump and what they want to do is
[__] irritate you to the end the you
know the Lord and Jes you know what man
it's [__] Monday at 2: in the
afternoon I'm watching Sons of anak on
[__] Netflix catch me I had a I had
them strung out for like 6 months you
remember that the one yeah they kept
knocking on your door when I was there
I've never SE talk to him for a couple
minutes and then Tom I was busy but you
know what come back next week come back
and the guy would come back and knock
again I tell him again this went on for
[__] months they disappeared I still
see them they come to the neighborhood
and they sit on the corner and they
dispatch like roaches like they sit on
the corner and they [__] go all four
directions and they knock is that
there's Mormon and then there's one
that's always by the bus station or the
train station they always have that
umbrella and they have like little
pamphlets do you know who do you know
those Lady it's always ladies and
they're always like really dressed
really Nic now they by the park by the
park in North Hollywood we used to go
for the [__] truck the the food truck
I think it's those same people yeah they
got them there in the daytime so you're
there exercising at 10: in the morning
there's three people sitting out there
in the [__] Park under an umbrella
giving out pamphlets for Jesus stop it
those are homeless people give me $5 and
go [__] yourself if I'm homeless and you
come to me with a pamphlet I'll beat you
with that [__] thing like I need
Jesus now I need I need $10 then we'll
talk about [__] Jesus later I seen
there's a homeless kid that lives in
that
Park he's a nice kid he comes over and
he's not like a pain in the ass he came
up to me one time at the Roach Coach
thing and I had an ATM card and I had
already paid but I had the baby and he
came home and he's like I'm I'm homeless
can you help me out Joey and I go dog I
have $3 on me I'll give you the $3
you're halfway there you know I got the
baby and the wife at me if not I go to
the [__] bank I had like an ATM that
day oh okay and then I saw him another
time and had a had to go meet somebody
like I was in a rush and I was driving
and I saw him and I pulled over and then
I saw him the other day with my daughter
and he came over and again I had no cash
I just had I was feeding the baby at the
park I took it to the [__] park to
play whatever the [__] that was and you
feel guilty you know especially this
time of the year you see
him listen man I [__] hate this time
of the year
really not that I hate it it just
doesn't feel right to me you know and it
and it hasn't felt right since I don't
know I don't know it just uh Josh Pacini
he's a black belt under Eddie in Chicago
runs a really great school Josh bini and
he wrote a an Facebook entry today about
you know while you're jumping up and
down there's people who have lost a
loved one
or uh you know just having a a bad time
you know I have a friend Mike in uh
Texas who I spoke to the other day and
he he just mentioned he goes it's not
going to be a great Christmas you
know and I didn't want to embarrass him
so I just sent him like 200 bucks just
to get you know a [__] sandwich or
something I know he's got a kid you know
I know what it's like to be [__] just
busted at Christmas you know busted at
Christmas it's a
horrible horrible feeling it's a you
know what the best Christmas I had was
I'll tell my best two Christmases okay
when I was seven I went to the bar with
my parents I had heard all these rumors
about no [__] Santa Claus there's no
Santa CLA there's no such [__] thing
as Santa Claus there's no such thing as
Santa Claus and I went to the bar with
them and we were having a great time and
when we got back to the [__]
apartment where we lived in 205 West
88th Street the [__] house was
covered with toys oh and I know both of
them didn't leave my [__] side all
night so I really bought into the Santa
Claus thing the house I still remember
we lived on 205 West 88th Street and
they moved the dinner table and put a
tree in the middle of living room it was
[__] amazing one thing about my mom
was she had The Uncanny gift to make
those holidays even better there's some
people who do that like they really know
how to make those holidays even better
they they really dive into it you know
and she was one of those people not just
Christmas birthdays you know little
things she really knew how to make them
better and then the best Christmas I had
the Christmas I realized what Christmas
was about was the Christmas I spent in
jail best Christmas in my life those are
two very different Christmases no
pressure it was really what Christmas
was about I want to see a Christmas
where a family goes you know what this
Christmas there's no expensive gifts
there's nothing we're going to get
together we're going to eat but we're
not going to give gifts we're just going
to eat and talk as a family blah blah
blah blah it's amazing how much pressure
gifts are cuz that's the only reason
people get upset during Christmas
pressure it's pressure I [__] hate it
I went to the mall to take a picture
with Mercy the other day my wife and
just walking around listen the trip to
New York with my wife that was Christmas
and I got a ring in New York I told her
go in there and pick a [__] ring to
match your wedding band that's Christmas
now Saturday I got to go hustle for her
birthday on Monday oh yeah you follow me
I'll go hustle for her birthday cuz her
birthday is on Monday but Christmas
we're adults we've done all the mercy
stuff and stuff but her birthday is her
birthday you know and uh I I can't go
Christmas
shopping it's
against you've ever you've gone shopping
with me you know it's a fast situation I
thought I was fast but you either got it
or you don't got it and there it is I'm
not going to stand here and read the
directions there let's go you know so I
don't have the patience the thing about
Christmas shopping is you really have to
have patience because I really know I
need to know what Lee
needs and that's a real Christmas
present I hate when people give me ideas
I don't want want anyone to give me any
clue I don't want to wish list I hate it
I want to I want to find it really see
that's what I'm saying you're such a
sweetheart of a guy for me you know what
I like doing that too but let's do this
let me give you a small hundred you go
get it yourself oh I like that that's
fine that's too I'm into that too listen
cash is a thoughtless
gift but not really are you with me like
it's a lazy man's gift like my mom used
to give me cash but then she'd scour the
face of the Earth looking for something
that I needed combined with something
that would Tickle My Funny Bone like
something that would really make you
happy to have like you carry it for 4
days with you you know what I'm saying
like that type of [__] when I was
younger I used to love gifts but now
this year when my mom came out I lit I
just said like can you help me with a
plane ticket for the for next year cuz I
I I was racking my brain for like an
hour day like not an hour day but over
the course of a couple weeks a few hours
there was nothing like I don't need any
there's a lot of stuff I would that
would be cool to have but I don't need
anything how would it change your life
there's a ton of stuff I like to have I
used to put all these movies down but
now I'm like I could just watch it
online or I don't really what are you
going to buy it for it's just you know
Mercy's a kid you got to shop for her oh
the kids love it but it's uh I always
felt that I don't have three weeks to
park go inside stores walk around
look or you know you know it's amazing
how Amazon and Target and all those
delivery people have taken to that [__]
and I'm one of those [__] people if
you could order it on Amazon's my best
friend you get GES on Amazon you get
oversized GES on Amazon you could get
belts on Amazon you get kettle bells on
Amazon you get Aid sneakers on Amazon
you get [__] I get the uh really good
catnip for the cats at Amazon I get
everything at [__] Amazon I love
Amazon but I had an issue today where I
just thought of some gifts for some kids
that I so want I I Googled toy store and
other than like the Hipster classic toy
stores on
Ventura there wasn't one there was one
in the mall but there was no way I was
going to the mall when I where I grew up
they had a it was called Learning
Express it was a toy store in a little
strip mall like I I love Amazon and I
use it for almost everything but I I do
kind of Miss like just stores a chain of
toy stores when we were kids toys okay
right okay but now you have these
Independents that are like everything's
[__] $22 more oh yeah but it's not
even toys that kids want it's like the
toys that like me like under 30-year-old
who wants to go vintage would get it's
and that's cool but like when I iend I I
found something different I wanted to
get my my girlfriend's nephews a a fart
machine cuz I got it when I was like
eight and that's how old they are they
didn't have it at Target so I got them a
little fart machine gun
and I just like that like that stuff I
like kid toys are always the best and I
like the reason why it meant so much to
me a couple weeks ago when you said like
Uncle Lee to Mercy like
I I love I love hanging out with kids
just being goofy and like her nephews
like like liked me last year so I want I
want to be like I had really
cool male cousins who are like 15 years
older than me when I was growing up so
like I like I would love to be that for
like mercy and like her nephews it's
just it's it's someone it's fun it's uh
it's different when you don't have kids
and you have little kids around you and
you really enjoy them it's fun because
you go home yeah and they stay there all
round up you giv them sugar and Coke and
[__] blowing shotguns in their faces
and there they are with their parents
like bye peace out and their parents
like uh Victor Eddie's friend had it
when his child was young like four he
was a Jiu-Jitsu kid and he was doing all
this [__] and I would we'd get him and
he'd look at us and go don't get him
started if you're not going to shut him
down if you're going to get them started
and leave don't do it walk away but if
you're going to get him started then
shut him down then you can hang he used
to say in Spanish
no which means don't turn it on if you
ain't G to turn this [__] off
and you would never turn it off no we
just walk away and leave them there
choking kids at the [__] at the UFC
events and [__] [__] hysterical but
oh Christmas is just
uh I get it I tell you what I like about
Christmas I like the stucking stuffers
yeah those little small gifts yeah I
like all that [__] my wife gets me a
calendar every year that's the best gift
I get of it's like a certain thing like
do you like pictures of certain things
no it's a calendar that I put in this
book that she got me like 15 years ago
when we first started dating so all you
have to do is just reorder the calendar
now oh it's like a little little
notebook or something a little
notebook I'm [__] sad to announce I
lost my [__] iPod oh man again again
again this is my favorite [__] iPod
Ralphie May gave me a stand from better
image learn whatever that is sharper
image Sharper Image where you just put
your pod the thing in there and it blast
they don't even make those no more so I
got to get rid of this now because that
iPod was for that go on eBay you could
buy that same iPod event really brand
new uh I don't know about brand new some
might say brand new yeah but listen
those things those iPods the longevity
of an iPod is how many times you [__]
drop it yeah okay so they dropped the
four times it might be that one drop
when I get it that that's it so with an
iPod you got to buy them new you got to
get all your drops in you know what I'm
saying you got to get all your own
[__] drops and I don't want somebody
dropping it four times I bring it home I
drop it there it goes [__] Elvis
sounds like [__] arita Franklin or
some [__] you don't like having music on
your phone cuz you don't even need I got
it on there now today I went to the
doctor and I put the [__] I put
Santana on in there and it was great I I
brought my iPod speakers they were
[__] great I got my iPod uh
headphones headphones that were [__]
great I just uh when you're on a plane I
don't want to use that juice what if the
plane goes down I need that juice to
call [__] and now I'm too busy
listening to [__] aliceon chains like
a jerk off yeah so if something happens
with the plane there I am with a half
[__] Juiced up [__] uh phone yeah
you're not because I want to be Joe jerk
off and listen to music that's why I
like to different I like to keep
everything different but I guess it's
the way to go it was pretty [__] loud
I couldn't hear the needle going into my
arm so it was obviously [__] pretty
loud
you could hear the needles no it's just
a [__] joke I didn't know if you were
like [__] needles but no uh when
yesterday I woke up a little [__] up
over it like I have a child now why
don't I
feel
excited like that's what I felt like is
like I have a child now why don't I feel
excited about Christmas and last night I
was having a hard time with it and I
kind of I'm not going to lie to nobody I
start feeling sorry for myself around
8:00 and and that's that's why I left
the house early last night I had to get
the [__] out of the house they were
driving me crazy really no not that
they're driving me crazy when you feel
shitty sometimes and it's a stupid
feeling shitty because I have no reason
to feel shitty like this about Christmas
just it just it's just a one day thing
for me you know just a one day thing
where I get kind of sour so last night
just left the [__] house early and
then I read Josh bini's post and I
remembered that this is a hard time of
the year for people you know and uh I
tell you man I had some [__] hard
Christmases embarrassing Christmases
where you have no money for nobody and
people invite you over to eat and you
show up with [__] like a bottle of
booze or something or like a bottle of
wine it's just a shitty time of the year
to be broke or be homeless or be living
on somebody's couches and I had all
those [__] years so I know how bad
Christmas can be you know so I'm going
to be periscoping a lot smoking pot with
people just [__] we'll Periscope a
Christmas movie or something like that
we'll Periscope uh the parade in the
morning whatever just just a [__] uh
you know just [__] around people get
people there's a lot of people who spend
Christmas alone yeah I was one of those
people what about the guys that spent
Christmas alone no girlfriend you know
what if you don't got a girlfriend I'm
the second best thing I'll show you my
dick whatever I'm Periscope whatever the
[__] I don't know Le do you have to show
them me no but I don't [__] believe
you know whatever whatever takes your
mind off that thing I was telling ter
you know I was telling yesterday and
that's when it got me yesterday at
breakfast I talked to Timmy my friend
Timmy and his mom died this year and
this is going to be the first Christmas
without his mom so I called him
yesterday morning I told him you know
I'll call him a few times and check in
with him and uh and when I hung up the
phone I thought about all the
Christmases that deep down inside I felt
[__] horrible but these guys made me
forget made me forget you you have you
have a break up with somebody
and every you think about them a lot for
the first two weeks and one night you go
out one of your friends and you get
drunk and you giggle and you talk to a
few girls and like halfway in the night
you're like holy [__] I'm not even
thinking about it no more like you have
to force yourself to think about that
person that's how it was sometimes with
those guys those Christmases like I
thought back I think in 79 after my mom
died I spent Christmas with the Benders
and just people in the neighborhood I
must have stopped over by Banos 80 I
spent with the Benders and people in the
neighborhood in 81 I spent with the
runnies and people in the neighborhood
you know because you would eat at your
house and then you go to other people's
houses and just sit around and watch a
game or a bowl game or a lot of people
would say Hey you know we're eating at
700 but at 9:30 people are coming over
you want to come over and we go over
there maybe do a couple bumps maybe
smoke a joint in the garage something
you know I never forgot those people
because they really made me
forget and and and I think it was till
about 86 when I need had to forget about
the holidays then after that I started
dealing with them and I started making
them the best I could right and then
when I went to prison that year that was
my best
Christmas because I realized what
Christmas was about the gifts and
everything it's something else it's a
state of mind that you're supposed to to
have during
Christmas and here were guys in a prison
that had the proper state of mind I
guarantee that those guys were just in
shock as I was and you're in the AIDS
unit right well I spent the Christmas in
the every guy went down and brought food
they had you know big TVs they had a
stereo on the age unit the age unit was
in 1985 1988 AIDS was [__] rampant
and people were petrify the AIDS so
these prisoners started suing in the
prisons because they didn't have normal
places of their own oh so they had to
build a unit just for these [__] guys
and it was state-ofthe-art
state-ofthe-art cabinets refrigerator I
mean all this [__] it makes you want to
get the hi I was just going to say Mak
you want to get to hien prison they had
better beds they had a a bunch of better
things in there refrigerators freezers
they could hide [__] in there you know
two or three of I think there were six
guys in the age unit five guys two of
them were still shooting dope in there
they were like we already have AIDS
might as well go down I didn't I I
didn't frown on them it was none of my
business I just they would go in the
back they would have
Lookouts but that Christmas I spent with
them I never seen so much food like I
was sitting there going I can't believe
I'm in prison I there was tamales and
burritos and tacos and pizzas and chili
and [__] a cake and Chinese or how
did they get all this a lot of people
brought food in like your your family is
allowed to bring your food in a certain
amount so we all put our Foods together
and and I remember looking around there
was black there was light-skinned black
dark skinned black African black white
you know there was uh Mexicans Indian
Mexicans chitaka Mexicans all in a room
now nobody had a beef people were
goofing people were joking and men with
AIDS and a gay
guy and everybody got treated with the
utmost [__] respect we giggled till
about 1:00 in the morning laughing
nobody one time said man I wish I had
alcohol man let's go smoke a joint I
wish we had joint it was just on your
own
Merit that's Christmas that's Christmas
when it's just no gifts I remember
waking up the next morning and going wow
that was virtually [__]
painless that's the most painless
Christmas I've ever had that I learned
about something was that like your first
Christmas back into the holidays or not
quite what do you mean back like you
said you you said you gave up the
holidays for a while
it's not that I gave him up the holidays
gave me up you know I wasn't in there
giving presents what I'm saying was it
was the State of Mind of the holiday oh
no I'm saying it was like a nice it was
the state of mind I remember looking
down the table and seeing you know 10
guys giggling eating these are guys that
are incarcerated you know yeah I had
like four years but there was some guys
in that room that had eight years there
was a kid that had DUI a vehicular
homicide nice white kid nice white kid
kid didn't belong in jail but he killed
somebody on New Year's Eve or whatever
the [__] he did Jesus and he was in
there so nobody was nobody was saying
nothing me that Christmas carols on and
it's hard for the people listening to
the podcast going Joey what are you talk
I'm telling you that it was as simple a
Christmas as can be but it it's amazing
how I learned about Christmas by going
to
prison because it was a bear back
Christmas food and
laughter and that's what it's about it's
that time of the year where you know
want whatever you're thinking about and
it's tough to say this whatever's going
on you have to put it
aside do you think it has to do with
like just cuz when you were saying like
your mom passed
away I had like a little mini panic
attack cuz now my mom is she's doing
fine but she's getting older so and then
it's getting to be more real that
eventually she's not going to be there
and I was just thinking if if I lost my
mom like the only thing I'd want is to
spend it with her like I wouldn't want
who cares about pres so is like that
maybe why like you don't you didn't care
about the Pres you just like the being
with people no man it's just
uh listen I'm not even talking about a
mom late you could lose an uncle that
was great on Christmas and Christmases
will never be the same and Uncle veto
again and Uncle Lou's again or the
carbon what's her name oh the Lombardo
the Lombardo God forbid I'm just saying
that it's always something everybody has
a either you do or you have something
going in we all dread that first holiday
without that loved one yeah and people
listening today I guarantee there's
three or four people listening to the
podcast maybe five that are going to go
into holidays without that loved one and
you're dreading it you're dreaden it
every time you [__] think about it
Jesus Christ you have no idea you have
no [__] idea but it's like I said in
the
documentary when you care for somebody a
blood one you know and they go on the
holidays or they go at with holidays
they
go sometimes your life isn't the same as
far as like what I told you in the
documentary it's like eating it's like
there's no taste there's no taste in my
food there's no salt in my food after my
mom died that's what it felt that's what
it felt like about life that the salt
had been taken out of my life yeah I
contined to live on I contined to do
things and do bad things and do great
things and good things but what was I
saying uh what after your mom passed
away that that's it that I don't even
know what the [__] we're talking about
I'm so high right
now but it's true we forget and I know a
lot of people listen and lost one it
listen man it doesn't matter you dread
that [__] day and when that day is
over you're so happy I mean nobody gives
a [__] about New Year's you think about
that person on their birthday your
birthday and the
holiday and then there's always that one
holiday that they went out of their way
for let's say they were good on
Halloween or the 4th of July every year
Halloween you're go [__] she'd be here
right now having a good time you know
and I feel I I feel for anybody who's
lost a parent trust me it's not going to
be as bad as you think say a prayer for
them when you wake up that morning spend
five minutes by yourself on the side
thinking about Christmas what Christmas
would have been like and then just dive
in and throughout the day you'll get
little shocks and at one point of the
day you might even be drawn to tears and
you might have to excuse yourself nobody
will see you do it just go to the
bathroom put some cold water water on
your face you know Pi pick up your chin
pull down your shirt and go back out
there and live with it deal with it and
just hope that they're watching and
they're there with you their spirit is
there with you and that's what you go
for you know for Christmas Christmas
sucks for some people but we make the
best of it we smoke a few joints you eat
a few lobster tails or a ham sandwich or
whatever you listen on Christmas you can
make a ham sandwich tastes like a
lobster tail you know just some Chinese
food but it's amazing what are you do on
Christmas day you going to swing by
picking Paul up I don't know cuz they
don't do much on Christmas like I'm
going over for Christmas Eve with them
um but have you ever seen on Facebook
they have like these Facebook groups
like JRE Island and like other stuff
like that it's like just a group of
people they added me to one and I don't
really do much on Facebook but they like
there's these people doing like a secret
Santa like they're sending gifts all
over the country and like they do all
these videos
and like it really it it's it's cool to
me me because I was one of those guys
like a nerdy guy like they all seem kind
of nerdy a little bit and maybe they
don't have a ton of friends where they
are but with the internet now like
especially what you're doing on
Periscope like people are staying in
touch you don't have to be alone it
doesn't matter if they're next it
doesn't matter you don't have to be
alone you know you have a and that's
this this afternoon after I went to
Perennial and bought that Gorilla Glue I
smoked some on [__] Periscope and as
I was doing it I said wow tomorrow if
everybody buys some weed and Friday
we'll get together a few times we'll
smoke I read the [__] comments I
answer back you know we'll just do it
for like 10 minutes here 8 minutes here
not to be Johnny annoying but just to
give you a break just to give you a
[__] break man that's it yeah I'm not
saying I'm going to [__] whatever but
I guarantee you it's better than just
[__] sitting there like a and you'll
be helping me out cuz maybe I'll be
going through my own [__] at the time so
I'll say you know what I don't need this
[__] let me go smoke a joint on
Periscope with these [__] Savages of
savages
so we were talking about that two weeks
ago I got up early one morning and uh I
went to the store on the way back I
parked the car and I was talking to
somebody and I ran up the stairs and I
must have held my breath and I got
upstairs and my
world like I had to run to the bathroom
and take my shirt off and sit I couldn't
sit I was get anxiety attack this is
when I used to had these breathing
things before in Jiu-Jitsu when I first
joined Jiu-Jitsu oh my God I was getting
these horrible anxiety attacks I stopped
eating Edibles before
Jiu-Jitsu and I stopped smoking pot and
it sometimes it would do it to me when I
was weightlifting you know like if I'd
be doing uh dead lips or something like
I'd go a little one extra and I would
miss my beat on the breathing and I
would get and it went away you know I
went to see uh this doctor and she told
me what to say when I got those feelings
and it went away and all of a sudden two
weeks ago it came back again and then it
came back Sunday at Jiu-Jitsu but it
really [__] hit hard yesterday they
kle out class yeah that was strange I it
was weird cuz you like we had just
started and you like kind of like went
to the side and like were holding on to
things it was scary it was [__] top I
could not breathe and the anxiety level
goes up and it's been teing I had the
anxiety attack at the store and I got to
be honest with you last night when I got
to the door of the store I got anxiety
if it wasn't for Sarah Tiana talking to
me she threw it off now I went to
acupuncture yesterday and I talked to Dr
Amy and I told her stick a couple extra
needles in me for the anxiety so I had
already in a doctor's appointment
tomorrow I was going to go talk to him
and see if I have ringworm it's not
ringworm I showed it to him it's just a
rash okay I thought you scared me with
all those diseases you [__] get so
the other day I get this thing on my
knee and I'm like that's ringworm I
didn't touch your knee so I went to the
doctor he goes it's not ringor and I
said look doc let me tell you what's
going on I told him my
situation he gave me an AKG and he drew
some blood this morning I was supposed
to go to Jiu-Jitsu this morning I stay
at the doctor's office till 11:30
so uh I'm waiting for the results before
I left the house I heard the computer go
off and he sent me the result to the AKG
and he says that it's a first degree
something in a valve electricity but he
goes it has nothing to do with the
symptoms I was saying so that's why he
called for a complete screen and my
thyroid and everything the [__] else so
let's see what happens I didn't faint I
didn't feel the [__] needle today G
this black woman is there used to be a
black woman there that used to wear a
wig like different color wig like blonde
wigs and blue wigs and purple wigs she's
not there no more the chick that
replaces a thicker wig like Anga like a
black thick she's beautiful she's
[__] beautiful and she's sassy and
[__] oh but dog I don't feel her [__]
needles at all in my arm cuz she talks
to you or something no I put Santan on I
only put Sant yeah she tells me you
ready to put your earphones on I put my
earphones on I give her my arm and I
mean she does it like that quickly no
[__] no chitter chatter no when she
comes in that [__] is ready ready once
she ties that [__] junky strap around
my arm I know it's time to go down to
the [__] murky Waters didn't even get
anxiety
nothing oh well hopefully that go like
with the acupuncture helps but how like
does he seem worried about your heart or
no we'll see tomorrow with the blood
test he says he's going to give me the
results tomorrow morning no he sent me a
thing he sent me the results of the EKG
goes no that's sleep apne type [__] oh
okay when you have sleep apne it wears
on your heart and all those years you
don't wear a machine it really wears on
your heart all that snoring and stuff oh
really yeah so that's why if you have
sleep apne they want you to to take care
of it as fast as you can but nobody
knows they really have sleep apnea so
you know they just keep thinking oh I
don't have it I just keep waking up I
think I did when I was heavier I don't
know if I used to do like Paul used to
have to wear headphon head earplugs
really I used to snore yeah I used to
snore you don't snore no more no she
doesn't have to wear the earplugs
anymore so I don't know maybe it's left
yeah it's less you lost 100 lb so it's a
lot less so that's yeah I I I used to
never want to fall asleep on planes I'd
be embarrassed I would be like I don't
know if I I don't know if I snore like I
don't give a [__] you pay for that plane
ticket that's your space in the air [__]
him if you snore I hope you brought
earphones [__] everybody got
everybody's got earphones now yeah very
seldom I I that happened to me on a
plane on I got thrown off a plane for
doing what for falling asleep and
snoring on a plane so loud before the
plane took off before the plane took off
I did
one like you're choking and the [__]
people around me got up and the stor
just came over and she's like are you
okay and I'm like yeah why she cuz you
were just choking at that you can't do
this what's wrong with you and like I
got to sleep at and she cuz you can't
fly on this plane like this I had done
like a one day without sleeping like one
of those shows I stay out till 3: and I
get back up and I got to fly at 4 it was
5:30 or something out of Houston they
put me on a later flight man they were
scared Jesus yeah I got thrown off the
[__] plant I mean I was choking to
death in those days Terry taped it for
me one time and she's like you got to
hear this and she taped it a long time
ago and you had to hear this you had to
[__] hear this at night it was
horrendous
horrendous Jesus I I was always people I
had a girlfriend record me once too and
I never knew people used to say you
sound like you're choking I like I don't
people like I never woke up not being
able to
breathe but it sounded like I had sleep
ABA that's the worst oh that's the [__]
you wake up oh you have no idea when you
wake up and you're out of air and you
got to fly off the bed and get
up so would you just like sleep on your
stomach uh I wouldn't
sleep I would sleep 2 three hours a
night that's it I was looking [__]
terrible I saw one of the pictures about
a month ago Terry showed me she goes I
want to show you when we first started
dating what he look like when the Sleep
happened he just wouldn't believe it you
just wouldn't [__] I was really
swollen
just swoll like how big were you do you
think swollen I was
360 350 360 it was
2001 easy
360 yeah terrible Health ter no working
out whatsoever not even a [__]
bicycle nothing nothing
years sometimes I would jump in a pool
with a hotel sometimes but besides that
never [__] worked out never walked
never did nothing would you used the
little hoverboards if they were out
there no no no that's for [__]
[__] Momos no I don't do that [__] I
never did nothing l i I drove to The
Comedy Store and I drove back that was
it my wife went to the store and got
cigarettes I stopped at 7-Eleven and got
him from time to time but I wouldn't
walk I didn't believe in walking at
all why not it was just too hard I would
make Rogan drop me off in front of the
hotels I got to park over there you're
going to [__] drop right here you you
better not park over there you better
drop my ass off right here you want to
be an Olympic Walker do it on your own
time you drop me off in front of that
[__] hotel these [__] used
to walk a mile away and walk [__] you I
don't need to walk Jack right there drop
me on Joey but no I don't give a [__] I
ain't walking that was the worst part
about Vegas when I was big cuz Vegas you
just nonstop walking I would dog I
wouldn't leave my room in those days
there was nowhere to [__] go once I
had the blow I would sit in that room
room till showtime and right after the
show I'd run back to that hotel lock
that door and do [__] powder I was in
horrible shape man that's why that sleep
happen you overtook me that strong I
used to fall asleep with and burn the
carpeting with cigarettes and Joints the
carpeting and that apartment I had to
buy new carpeting Jesus I had to [__]
buy new carpeting for the whole living
room did you ever like set the floor on
fire oh my God Terry came out one night
and caught it just in time the bottom of
it had gone through it was just just
basically a lot of times I would just
drop the cigarette and fall asleep for
10 minutes or something and then catch
it and put the Flames out this night it
burnt through the carpeting it started
burning that [__] underneath oh Jesus
and it was like from 1920 so the stuff
was [__] and she woke up and smelt it
and she was pissed I bet pissed at that
time they had to be guys I'm not lying
to you 40 burn marks in the carpet and
what would your excuse be I fell asleep
she knew I had sleep apnea and those
days I used to go to bed at 2:00 and
wake up at 3:30 and I was up that's it
up up would you nap later in the day
what nap I what why would I nap for to
wake up
choking Jesus not getting sleep is not
good no and then I went to Little Rock
Arkansas and I [__] had to get picked
up you know how the club picks you up in
the front of the hotel but I be down at
7:45 we'll pick you up I sat on the
couch and I fell asleep and I started
making those
noises and some guy woke me up and he
says he gave me his card he says I'm a
physician do you live in town and I go
no he goes listen man we just sat here
and watched you you're going to die
that's exactly what this guy said to me
oh no he goes I could tell by the color
of your skin you're not getting oxygen
you have no oxygen in your blood he goes
I want you to go to the doctor when you
get home this is an
emergency you will not make the
month
really he told me I was not going to
make the month he goes you're choking in
your sleep and he started asking me
questions and he looked at me seriously
in the eyes and he's like here's the
deal you have sleep atne here but yours
is Extreme not to mention your
overweight to the gills don't he was
like I hope you're not embarrassed by me
saying this angry with me he goes you're
really overweight and he goes and you
you you're just telling me that your
blood pressure is really high and I was
lying to him like oh it's like 140 goes
no it's not he goes listen let me take
your pulse and he was taking my pulse
and he's like listen your 3/4 is dead
you don't even know yet you're going to
have a heart attack because every time
you do that you get stuck your heart uh
does something not that it stops but it
it puts a strain on your heart Jesus
Christ just in a hotel lobby just so dog
I got home I told Terry Terry [__]
called and she went down there I mean
held my hand throughout the whole
[__] thing cuz I kept saying if they
give me one needle I'm out of
there and you were just going to like
take it just be like yeah no I was just
going to go down there and see what they
said and then they did the thing then
they sent me in for a sleep
study where you have to put the machine
on they take the air off and they see
where you choke and now they know they
give you an accurate number and then I
got a machine and I tell you man within
60 days it changed my
life you have to take care of this thing
maybe I should go get a check down I'm
really no no because you're losing
weight now and it's this weight around
here that really helps oh okay it's this
weight around your neck you know if you
lose that you know when you have 19
[__] necks that don't help nobody you
know I got this little chicken neck
there but that's from being old that's
not having the [__] 18 [__] necks
my neck when I look at those pictures
you ever see my driver's license my neck
is huge that's the worst part about a
picture it's the I hate it no so if you
have the sleep apne you really really
[__] have to take care you don't know
what I went through with that thing you
have no [__] idea and now I have it
down to a science like I don't I don't
put it on unless I go to sleep I don't
go in the bedroom there's a science
behind it like people won't use it
because they they train to do it wrong
the guy that trained me Jimmy I still
communicate with 15 years later I still
talk to my sleep at their coordinator I
send him PR present from time the time
he comes to my shows when I'm in Orange
County he came to Irvine I like what he
do like how did he help you because he
told me the process the process isn't
just getting your machine and going home
you know it's like the numbers are
staggering how many people go home get
the machine get the [__] sleep study
and then put the machine on and feel
uncomfortable because of like the mask
because the mask okay and then they give
up on the mask and then they sleep at me
and they get all the problems that come
with it what I did was he told me all
these little things he goes I don't want
you to go into that bedroom till you're
going to go to sleep
he goes I'd rather you fall asleep in
the living room and walk in and put the
mask on than go in there and put the
mask on and try to fall asleep because
then if you're that tired you're not
going to give a [__] if it's a little
tight right oh okay yeah my dad tried it
once he said he said he couldn't deal
with the mou no he couldn't people can't
and then they either do the mouthpiece
or they have to lose weight or do the
surgery you know there's a bunch of
different options the surgery is just
your two time it takes you out of the
game too long the recovery is painful
the older you are the worst it is they
got to open up [__] Rogan had it but he
didn't have the full sleep at anything
they just cleaned out his nose oh for
him to breathe weather which I need to
do I need to clean out my [__] nose
to breathe better that's another issue I
have just what like what just I don't
know what they do I don't know what the
process is called I kind of want to get
my ears done I think that what's wrong
with your ears nothing just get like the
wax taken out well then you got to go to
a place you don't clean your own is
every day well I I do but they say don't
use Q-tips they say what you mouth with
no that's what I use sometimes but they
like I've seen videos they have like
these little scrapers and they just go
in and like really get it out of there
you watch videos on people cleaning
their ear yeah it's either what is wrong
with you I don't I don't search it out
but people post it on Facebook I don't
watch listen man Q-tips suck Q-tips are
the biggest ripoff the cuz everybody
knows a big pen is the best thing you
can [__] clean out your ears the cap
of a [__] big pen takes all the
chunks out it pisses me off when you go
home take a shower you come out of the
shower you [__] the reason why I use
Q-tips is to take the moisture out of my
ear excuse
me that's what I use Q-tips for to take
the moisture out of my ear so you don't
get like an infection so I don't get
those [__] ear infections from
swimming that's what happened to me I
leave the water in there so now I take
it out sometimes I get in the car and I
have fuel fluid in my ear and it [__]
pisses me the [__] off so I got Q-tips
in the car now
but you you would never get it like
scraped out if it was that [__] bad
but I take care of my ears I mean I get
pissed off when I put a Q-tip in there I
see wax yeah because I just clean it
this morning where' this [__] wax
come from where' this buildup come from
sometimes you forget you pull out like a
[__] purple chunk that shit's
disgusting but they have places now
where you could steam clean your ears or
something yeah how much are they I don't
know I could look it up have you ever
done a a CO what's a hydrocon thing like
they cleanse you no you would never do
that
listen it was bad enough putting the
camera up my [__] and taking the
pictures for the colonoscopy to do the
colonic yeah that's what it's called
yeah colonic when you stick a coffee
colonic up your ass the tube and they
clean you out I would consider it it's
just embarrassing my ass smells oh yeah
I got to bend over and let somebody put
a tube in your ass if I could do it
myself i' do it that's just a little
embarrassing and then seeing people what
comes out of your stomach there's chunks
and legs and chicken bones God knows
what comes out your stomach with that
Subway sandwich that's what I was just I
was thinking like all the fast food I
used to eat it might be I I almost cuz
didn't like Elvis have like 50 lbs of
like [__] and where can you do a colonic
around here where have you heard seen
have you seen the sign I've seen signs
seen Groupons for it which kind of
scared me but yeah I don't know I just
thought i' I've thought about it I tell
you if you're got to do one group on is
the [__] way I can you don't think
that's like why are they on Groupon like
I want to pay like full price for
because there's 20,000 of these things
listen there's a thousand great
Jiu-Jitsu schools 10 of them are on
Groupon even cobr cobr is one of the
best schools in California around here
and he's in [__] Groupon just to get
but you could only use it for certain
classes at
cinus oh okay you know there's certain
things when I got my toenails [__]
blow torch to get the fungi out of them
what do you think I got the special from
[__] group on where do you go to get
fun Tour Boulevard right there in
Sherman Oaks is it like a a salon it's a
Salon it's like a tattoo removal they do
everything there as long they got a blow
torch that blow torch Burns everything
down no they you do you go in the back
you take your socks off and they put
like this air conditioning tube on your
toes okay so your toes get cold so you
won't feel the torch they have a little
like it's a fire torch it's like a
little torch that like a
laser it's a hot laser that burns the
fungi under your nail and then I I'm
supposed to put ointment on my nails
after the shower and keep them I'm clean
and [__] my nails look like [__] de
what happened I don't know I don't know
what happened so I told the doctor today
and he say he's going to look in to give
me a pill to kill that fungi but that's
what he gave me the blood test for to
see if I had any funguses what the
extent of it is in my blood system or
whatever which I do I do have a fungi
that's why you H that fungi now there's
a funy that lives in your [__]
toenail a lot of people don't know that
[__] now you know [__] I had no
idea that the fungus just I isn't there
a commercial for that like lman or yeah
lman there's a there's a stuff you but
I'm beyond lman it look it fights it off
oh God it's it's it's the nail swells oh
God and the fungi goes under the nail
and you have to get like a thing soak
your nail and then take a clip and take
those things out and I save them [__]
throw them at people on a plane no you
don't you just uh I just [__] uh
whatever the [__] you ask question oh
yeah what do they smell like horid so
let me let me ask you a question cuz I
did not know about this somebody asked
me the other day and when Esther cou was
here they asked me what happened with an
kumia I think he just I haven't seen a
followup to it but the article I read
said his girlfriend started
periscoping and she was like he hit me
and he was like get out of my
house and and then it cut off but then
he I think he got arrested but he was he
did a show so he must have got bailed
out I can look it up see if there's no
no he made bail saw something on the
news that Anthony Kia from op and
Anthony hit his
girlfriend and and I you know like when
you're involved in something and you see
it online but you don't digest it yeah
that's what happened to me like I didn't
really [__] digest what had
happened yeah it's great it's
uh and then I I didn't listen to all of
it but then there was a thing with Opie
and and Jim they were fighting about
about Anthony a little bit so and that
he doesn't seem like he's a that nice of
a guy I don't know what
happened uh pinned her against the wall
and strangled her
tremendous and then stomped on her hand
no he didn't that's what it said on
CNN H Jesus I wish him luck or whatever
happens there she was like a drunk
something she was drunk or something
were they drinking probably yeah I mean
they it said it was after an
argument and were they bar no they were
his
house they at his house to see if
there's anything
else well I wish him luck that's always
a tough one to get out of I had one of
those it's a [__] nightmare some
drunk chick comes over your house
yelling [__] so BL was his girlfriend
yeah okay then it's not a drunk chick
I'm
sorry uh no it doesn't yeah was his
girlfriend doesn't doesn't say anything
about
drinking that's messed up it's happening
a lot now
did he hit her on Periscope no Periscope
came after it's she was just saying it
happened yeah did you hit somebody on
Periscope you're done they got you on
[__] camera oh my
God it sucks all that [__] sucks when it
happens Jesus
Christ like fighting with somebody oh
all that [__] sucks when you have to get
involved with people and then the cops
come
and so I I feel for him I just didn't
know he got arrested and stuff I thought
he got into an altercation that's what I
had thought or read or whatever but
what's the [__] difference you know
what I'm saying an altercation you get
arrested no and I mean we don't know the
post both sides of the story maybe she's
crazy yeah well to every [__] there's
always two sides let me give some shout
outs first off I want to give a Merry
Christmas to all you [__] that
are stuck it out with us and if uh
whatever I was talking about hit a coure
with you you know I love you and I got
you back tomorrow send me an email we'll
talk about it whatever you want to do
I'm at church G gmail.com but I want to
give shout outs to Leon Constantine rain
my main man water boxer Cleo you know
Okie spooky who I haven't seen on there
for a couple days maybe she's in jail
you know Okie spooky loves yelling at
people and [__] the tuna number one
Michelle gugan John Wolf J the art of
combat Misty Mayhem JT and Jim na Jim na
was the one that was telling me about uh
YouTube and all that [__] whatever the
[__] happened oh okay YouTube was out
when I got home he emailed me tweeted me
and said YouTube was [__] out why am
I stuttering [__] mumbling here you
know what I'm saying cuz we had 600
milligrams well I had like 200 you son
of a [__] I can't eat 600 I'll [__]
I'll go get the anxiety attack I just
wanted to I wanted to uh uh just tiptoe
around it for a few days just to see dog
how long you know me you know I'm back
you know I never give up I just got to D
wait till I get the blood test and then
we'll confirm if there there's nothing
wrong I'm I'm eating Edibles for
Christmas Day [__] did you ask them to
like just get a THC level on your blood
cuz they're doing it you should do it
you should just be like how much is it
leave those THC people alone what is
your infactuation with this THC [__]
leave it alone I don't want to know
what's in my blood I don't want to know
what levels are in my [__] blood I
don't know want to know how many
carbohydrates nothing you just want to
know if you're going to live or not
that's just want to know if you're
healthy or not yeah I just want to know
what the [__] was causing this maybe
it's my thyroid the medication because
the medication they give me is made from
cow thyroid so sometimes you sometimes
they they got little cows than bigger
cows so they give you the wrong amount
so maybe that's it so he's going to look
and see what the numbers are and maybe
prescribe a different thyroid medication
for me to either speed it down or shut
it down whatever the [__] going on
with my thyroid I told you what happened
last night right at the store last night
was [__]
craziness I'm jealous it was just
craziness but it was something that kept
me up and woke me up early this morning
it really was the art when people really
like
you you could say whatever you
want when people really like you when
you got them sucked into your
world you could say whatever you want
and nobody
has that going on More Than A guy by the
name of Dave
Chappelle I have seen it before but last
night it was [__]
spectacular you know I was sitting there
with first I got to the store and they
had two special guests they had arcenio
and nor McDonald Bobby Lee was on stage
Nicki Glazer was on stage Ari was on
stage Ari was bringing me up as I'm
sitting at the bar inside just talking
to Jerry roacher Dave Chappelle walks in
he comes off we start chitchatting about
Ohio why he lives
there and I go sit down and next thing
you know they come in they go hey he
wants to go on next you mind I go [__]
no he's Dave Chappelle I'm happy I'm
happy I'm here I'm going to watch him
you know and uh cuz you always learn
something when you watch those guys you
know cuz there's not a lot of people
that I think you would let bump you like
how no no no listen I'm the type of guy
that I'm not I don't play that ego [__]
if you have a legit excuse you know and
you're the man I don't give a [__] it's
the people that come on and try to give
you some story um I have another spot no
no no no no you're going to do this spot
when you're supposed to do it that's it
and they look at you all weird and they
work it out cuz half of those guys will
tell you they got to go somewhere else
and when you get off stage they're still
there talking in the hallway right I
thought you had to go somewhere else um
yeah they just called and they said they
were running late no they weren't you
just didn't want to follow me you foll
me you just didn't want to so don't
worry but don't don't ask oh okay don't
ask so a lot of people just want to get
on stage a showc whatever no no no he's
Dave [__] Chappelle okay when I was
an open micer I paid to see Dave
Chappelle in
1993 when uh Robin Hood Men and tights
came out at the Boston comedy club with
Nick depalo and Felicia Michaels and
[__] amazing open MK so and then I
got to work with him a few times and
then I did the the tour and I saw him
and and that's when he was like where
the [__] you been and we talked a little
about and then last night we talked so I
have nothing against the guy I think the
guy [__] brilliant you know and the show
was so Cutting Edge but nothing they
have not forgot about him listen I've
been at the store when Louis CK goes up
and I'm at the store
when uh Chappelle Chappelle goes up and
I got to tell you they give more
Applause for Chappelle and it's white
people well he never I never I never see
him around I saw him right after he came
back from
Africa at the AIS Arena and like be's
Arena and he it was I I don't even I
remember all
I my friend got the tickets but I
remember I was sitting and the the one
joke I remember was like he was like how
would you like to get like $60 million
but then someone puts like a big huge
dick on it I'm like get the money now
I'm not going to I I can't do what he
did but that's like I just cuz that show
was hu the biggest show forid my age he
was talking about last night that he
should have taken the $50 million really
yeah he was talking about Cosby that
[__] Cosby is Gangster because he's
suing the [__] that he raped you know
that is pretty [__] up he said some
great stuff he's so insightful that's
what makes him a good comedian but at
the same time it's a time he's put in
you know he was an apprentice for a
while you know that right he was an
apprentice to one of the funniest guys
of all time I mean I love Charlie
Barnett I adore Charlie Barnett nobody
has made made me laugh more than Charlie
Barnett I've never even heard that name
put on Charlie Barnett YouTube and let's
go to the screen Here Charlie Barnett
was a black guy from the 70s he was in a
movie
called Damn with Mr
T and uh I guess he was doing standup
and Michael man seen him somewhere and
put him on Miami Vice let's put it on
the big screen see we got Charlie
Barnett the legend goes that Charlie
Barnett used to take Dave Chappelle with
to Washington Square Park on Sundays
when I was a kid growing up you could go
to Washington Square Park and there'd be
a black guy doing comedy every week for
free that was Charlie
Barnett there you go there you go check
this out Char look at look who the [__]
do you think you're dealing
with at Washington Square Park that's
Charlie [__] Barnett do you
think he gave a [__] zero [__] we got a
ni crowd
here I love a New York
audience I mean look at this crowd we're
in the village I love the village we got
a nice mixed crowd I mean look what we
got we got white
folks we got black
folks we got Puerto
Ricans Puerto
Rican we got a lot of [__] Puerto
but I'm not going to [__] with the you
see what I'm saying cuz y'all B I just
gave you [__] a history lesson
you understand me you keep playing it
and when you finish you go geta bro cuz
I got into a fight with a Puerto Rican
kid and I was winning I was bouncing
around like Sugar Ray linen I was bam
bam bam it was only about that t no
microphone then all of a sudden a park
in the middle of a park people and I was
surrounded by a small Puerto Rican
Family of
4,000 I like everything let me B it
okay I like pocket books I love pocket
books I like the way white women walk
with their pocket book when there's no
Negroes around I don't see no
[__] where do you think Dave do you
understand me people what you just
listening to everybody goes to work
different that was his ccasian
businessman I need some white people
glasses did they do it on the street
together look at yes Dave Chappelle was
in the audience Dave Chappelle open for
in a [__]
part damn you can't see
[__] that's improv gu at the
park how do white guys go to work they
got their
briefcase I can walk just like the white
man going to work watch this white guys
[Laughter]
I love when they stand on the corner and
go I put Charlie Barnett on Miami Vice
start to work we be talking
about if you've never [__] seen
Charlie Barnett this guy he died for
maids and uh it was
something
right right there the first one the F
right there this is when he deals with
Mr Castellano right here watch this this
was on the other morning and that's you
got your Ronald Reagan you got your leaa
you got your raldo Rivera and that's how
you stay on top that's how you get that
job done organization
[Music]
hey tremendous this is so I guess he saw
him look at they're really freaky
looking guys but I figured somebody
wants to move 2,000 pieces you ought to
hear about it can they deliver I mean
they talk like big business that was
make to the part about the money the nug
man's got plans for the evening and he
needs his cash money dollar bill this
guy's got a lot in a cabesa man he's
going to spend all his time in the
swimming pool going to need an
underwater camera all right who now
maybe you're not familiar with Mr cust
out of style who yourself Jack well
maybe you're not familiar with Mr nman
stop you not familiar with Mr nman are
you [__] kidding me or what that's
charie Barnett right there the
noie so I guess uh and then he got fired
when he beat up Don
Johnson this guy was the real deal
ladies and gentlemen any other tapes of
that Charlie Barnett doing stand up
there's one of Chappelle talking about
Barnett all right put him on that's it
got guys you have no [__] ideas you
have no [__] idea how strong this guy
was I had a conversation with with
Andrew Dice Clay and Paul Rodriguez and
Paul Paul Rodriguez said he he uh there
you go he uh went to see him in the
hospital and that he was still [__]
hilarious
spot got a SP hey Dave real you start
out you start out in the stre right
watch yeah how you go I'm Tony I ioke
with Charlie about
that oh Tony yeah how you doing the fire
guy yeah how you doing man I remember
you yeah and uh an Al and everybody yeah
cuz I I remember I went back to New York
I saw you in the fountain I was amazed
yeah you went uh they used to uh they
used to ride the
um that
was yeah at waston Square Park man lost
this we we ony Spirits you know I do P I
quit drinking and smoking so I do Pap
work it gets me high you know and we
really they said you were here and we
want bris coming in right nowy Spears
she be in about 20 minutes but we didn't
care you want to come me her we didn't
care you were coming in and had to get
you long
from man you have no idea so you could
see by the the first three lines that
Charlie Barnett said where he got that
little racism eyeball from you know when
you go up in front of and when you work
with Charlie Barnett all the [__]
time and you watch this guy that was
what we just saw was improvised no
microphone you know the microphone's a
control that's what you like the whole
the reason why you have a microphone is
because to show the audience it's like a
control you have control when you don't
have a microphone you're just any other
swinging dick
talking he was doing that with no
microphone every every Sunday and
Saturday he do that for hours late hours
how long will the shows like 20 30
minutes when I just tell you hours well
oh I thought maybe he'd stop and he stop
he'll go eat and and Chappelle would do
time and then he' come back and do
another [__] 35 40 [__] minutes
that's unheard of Lee and they did that
every Saturday and Sunday Washington
Square Park I used to go around the
corner of a place called mcy zail house
and they would give you three mugs for a
dollar and while I was in there my
friend would go into the park that same
park and buy volumes and heroin and he'd
come back to moles and give me my
volumes and he'd take his heroin and go
shoot it and I'd eat like two v's and
drink three mugs of beer and I'd walk
around won Square Park all [__] up
Jesus Christ that was the old days lead
but you know what I watched that and I
got to be honest with you when I watched
it I'm not going to lie to you I had no
inclination of comedy in my life at that
time I saw saw him and I was like this
guy's brilliant but like in those days
when I knew about Charlie Barnett I had
no I was a fan of Charlie Barnett
everybody else was a p fan of you know
George Carlin and Richard Pryor I was a
fan of Carlins and Pryor but I was a
bigger fan of Charlie Barnett because
Charlie Barnett had what I wanted when I
started getting into comedy then I
really got into Charlie Barnett because
he had what I wanted he had something
that a lot of people can't do he could
be talking to you to stand up and act
and he's all the same person now there
somebody who's listening to this like
Joey then why act I don't know I
like what what I mean is he put
personality into his characters that he
was in a movie what the look up Charlie
Barnett on IMDb what was the movie he
was in [__] great movie it's like a
Mr T and A bunch of other
guys let's
see
he Chicago Fire the happy sadman and
Black 3 Gabby private Romeo no no no no
no Charlie Barnett look him up again he
only no he only had a couple credits
like Miami Vice but he was in a movie
about a junkyard or something like
that he's on Mi DV all right press Mr T
how's that okay hold on let's see if Mr
T's been in
Cuz Mr T was in the [__] movie with
him that
movie DC C DC C there you go Charlie
[__]
Barnett so when I saw him in DC cab I'm
like wait a second what year DC cab come
out 1983 yep way before [__] Miami
Vice and when I saw DC cab I was like
this guy is doing something like he's
being
himself in his acting
listen I acted for years and I could
never be myself till I was in the Marin
show I do Marin that's me that was the
first time first time I was ever Joey
Diaz in the show I and Marin that's when
I was me that's why I really like that
episode because I got it after [__]
15 years of acting I got it I learned
how to put me into a role I was always
very scared I just read the lines from
the paper and did minimal movement when
I did Marin I got it
what comedy comedic acting is I got it
and if you look at when I did Brooklyn
99 I had it but I didn't want any
movement I just sat in a chair so I had
to find ways to be so I just killed
myself and said how about I just don't
move and just look at him and don't move
and don't only move my left hand because
you know you follow me it's very tough
to put your personality into a role he
figured out a way and he did the same
thing in DC cab and he did the the same
thing in Miami Vice even though it was
two different characters he was the nman
on Miami Vice and he was the noogie but
he put his personality into it which to
me is really [__] impressive man I
love that [__] you know like good actors
like good actors like so what is what
does it feel like when you're not in the
zone like what if it doesn't feel do you
can you not get into it
or we we saw something this week we
might as well talk to the people about
it we saw the special this week that I
was shot in Vegas okay you did a great
job salami did a great job you know who
did a shitty job me we all have to I'm
telling you I was just talking through
emotions when you if you would have
taped Sunday night set when people left
mad and I was just up there rapping
that's what we should have taped we have
we actually have salami taped it it's
just like a one static shot of it though
right but that's that's who I am
maybe we'll that [__] I did on the
special that's not me I was doing the
special I was saying the words it it it
take somebody I could have blamed
everybody I could have put the blame on
a lot of things on that special but I
didn't I wasn't in the
zone no matter what you do to it put
sound to it whatever we'll release it
later in
chunks just so they see it we'll get a
bit from it that maybe I wasn't maybe
something I said but I wasn't in the
zone and I didn't know that till Sunday
night oh after You' already
taped I knew this going in I knew this
going in I wasn't in the zone I repeated
lines just what you showed me I repeated
lines I it just wasn't the Zone you're
supposed to do a warmup first and then
that and I just wasn't in the zone and
it's nobody's fault the the the the the
last three days I've learned more about
standup you always learn when you watch
yourself I don't watch myself cuz I hate
watching myself I don't want to ever
look at me ever I don't want to hear my
[__] voice I don't want to do
nothing yeah but when I sat there and
watched that with you why do you think I
left here like my [__] was on fire
cuz I went to the car and made
notes and then I went to the store last
night and I had to follow Chappelle and
the same thing happened I went up there
and I did material but I wasn't in a
Zone I didn't I wasn't me I was too
caught up in Chapelle it happens man
right it [__] happens it's it was
tough for me the past couple I would had
like
not I was really excited to to work to
work on and and I I
put like I I really did like I thought a
good job J but no and I have to give you
credit because there's a lot of people
like you you brought it
up and Paton Oswalt is one of my
favorite Comics but he has a special
that came out that he has a string on
his jacket and the first thing I said to
you after I saw it how how could someone
not sit do that
so for you not to release a special that
you think isn't up to par I think a lot
of people wouldn't do that some people
it's not what I do it's not what I do I
didn't put any thought into it I wore
the wrong clothes
I didn't have a production assistant
somebody that walk me through you know
we thought people were going to show up
on Saturday never showed up they left us
with a dick in our hand you know we
didn't really have a relationship with
those camera guys so we couldn't really
sit them down we had a meeting for how
long 20 minutes yeah and they had a tiny
room that all you know when Ronda Rousey
got kicked in the head yeah when Ronda
Rousey fell and she got back up and they
were talking to her remember the UFC
released that footage and they're like
do you know where you are whatever
questions they were asking her you know
what Rhonda was thinking about what all
the mistakes she did leading up to that
fight that Sunday when she didn't meet
the trainer because she was tired or you
think about all the things you didn't
do okay and that's what happened when I
looked at that special I thought about
all the things I didn't do I reacted a
lot better than I did when I went to
meet Kev because that pissed me off that
day when we met with that guy and he was
telling me what I wasn't doing right
okay we did it we shot it and that's
where the pride is the pride would have
been if we would have backed on it and
said nah let's not [__] shoot it like
I I've done a thousand times we did it
and now we we're stronger and we know
for the next time the investment I lost
forget about it happens what are you
going to do we'll make it up later it's
I didn't want to put out a bad product
to these people it just didn't look
right to me let's send it to our guy
let's see what he looks like when it
comes back and we'll make a final
decision but just from what I saw I
wasn't
myself next time when I shot a special I
don't want to
know you don't want to know what that
I'm shooting the speci okay I don't want
to know I just want to Sho oh that's to
that's cool because I just don't want to
know oh that could totally happen I'm
just going to give you money and say
shoot a special don't tell me where
these are the cities you got an option
and you just do it on your own and you
show up to all of them to keep tricking
me don't just show up to one city go I
just came to watch no shoot it because
if you don't then I'm not going to take
you for granted okay so I don't want to
know the best sets I've had is nobody
tells me they're shooting me and after I
do it they come up to me and they go hey
dog I shot that I taped that for you no
you didn't yes I
did you know San Diego last Saturday uh
Thursday first show was [__] I improv
for the first 20 minutes and [__]
estou taped it so she sent it to me so
do you follow me leave all these things
now and then last night following
Chappelle all those little things are
going to make me
better I could look at that special as
two things let's set it out so I can get
what I recoup back but it's not really
me anywh you put it we're going to get a
special from somebody this year so I'm
not really worried about it or Joe the
manager will hook me up with the people
who do the special correctly and we'll
get a Live Nation joint and we'll do it
correctly yeah but to put that out to
insult people you know the people who
are going to look at that are people who
can't see me in Ireland and England and
people like that I don't want to [__]
uh for the $5 I don't want to insult
them I rather [__] just light the
thing on fire and move on with my life
and we'll shoot another one that's how
you do it but I'm not going to put
nothing you know most people release a
CD every year I release one every two
years is it because I'm a bad comic no
because I want to give you and you just
released the CD the CD I love the CD I
love Savage dead the one before that
eating [__] that's another thing that's
garbage I didn't really it wasn't my
best the one before that you and the
priest I love it I love it I really do
night at the three of Spades ah ah you
know that's before my time I I haven't
listen to that I that's a long time ago
so but at least I'm honest a lot of
people tell you that this is great no
it's not man and not every album could
be great nobody tells me more about bad
specials than yours truly you nobody
comes here every week and goes my God I
watch this special Jesus it was bad what
was wrong with it Le they shot it bad
they did this bad they did this bad
nobody correct or no right yeah so
that's the [__] other side of this I
want to be honest with people and just
say and you know people ask us every
[__] day when is the special coming
up when is the special coming up we got
other [__] we're going to shoot people
so don't never feel the
reaper yeah and I'm I'm I'm going to
finish whatever we have and we'll send
it over we'll see what happens we'll see
what happens maybe Netflix will pick it
up and maybe we'll add something to it
maybe we'll dope it up I have no [__]
idea maybe you can cut it down to like
15 20 good minutes or something even
I'll chop it down to 30 minutes and put
it on do a 15 minute [__] special I I
really don't give a [__] you know what
I'm saying I just don't want to release
something that uh that they're not going
to be happy with me I want people to be
happy I want you to be happy and most
importantly I want to be [__] happy
you know what I'm saying right speaking
of happy you want to be [__] happy
underwear that's what makes me [__]
happy it needs to be comfy snug in all
the right place it's got to look good
it's got to feel good you just don't
want to wear un you just don't want
underwear that are comfy you want the
world's most comfortable underwear and
that's meundies I've been pushing
meundies for a [__] year and there's
a reason I love them I got a black pair
on right now every pair of meundies is
made with a micro modor fabric which
doesn't sound sexy but once you feel
your meundies you'll never go back to
regular [__] cotton underwear again
with meundies you'll feel more
comfortable than ever before before not
to mention meundies has a ton of
different colors to choose from and it's
the only and it's the only place to find
styles for both men and women with a new
signature design every goddamn month and
now the holidays are here you can't get
one but hey you could still order them
and they make a perfect gift after the
fact oh I didn't see you for a couple
days if you order right now I guarantee
you'll get them in a [__] few days
next week so trust me these are not your
parents ducking stuff is do me a favor
go to meundies.com jooy right now I'm
going to give you 20% off your first
order plus all orders in the US and
Canada I'll ship them to you for free
all right meundies even has a money back
guarantee if you don't like the first
pair we send you you keep it and you get
a full refund that's it you have
literally nothing to [__] lose you
know I like I said it's too late to
order now for tomorrow or or whatever it
is Friday Friday but you can still order
today and get them like Monday or
Tuesday and just show up oh my god look
what I forgot to put in the bag so for
your 20% off your first order and the
the world's most comfortable underwear
head to meundies.com
pressing Joey right now that's
meundies.com
joeey and get 20% off the most
comfortable underway you ever [__]
put on in your life all right other
people I want to give a shout out to
today is my favorite favorite favorite
that's another thing I'm not I like and
I didn't have shroom
Tech I2 you didn't have it before gg2 no
I didn't have I'm out of it I have to
call them so I didn't want to call them
last week cuz it was the holiday week I
knew they would be busy with with orders
so I just said let me hit them up the
first and tell them I need I need more H
protein more shroom Tech sport so when I
went to kettle bells you and I had those
heart palpitations usually I'll get one
of those but it'll move on with the
shroom Tech gives you that extra [__]
boom like you got but I didn't take
anything that's why I'm scared if I
would have taken the shroom Tech I would
have go oh it's the shroom Tech but it
wasn't the godamn shroom Tech but anyway
we're just talking about on it and the
things I use before I work out whether
it's a shroom Tech sport I I use the
shroom Tech immune before I fly you know
I don't use the te booster because I'm
Cuban I got tons of testosterone but the
hemp Force protein is [__] the best
sweetest tasting chocolate you've ever
tasted in your life go to honor.com
right now and/ church church chur CH I
get 10% off your first order delivered
right there to your house on it again
the best whether you want the kettle
bells the hemp Force protein I mean they
just got and then keep going on it.com
because they keep adding it adding great
stuff all the goddamn time they just got
a Jiu-Jitsu they're 10 Planet Jiu-Jitsu
now on it go to hit.com right now and
press in church boom and they have a
bunch of great videos my dad got a kle
bill DVD from them he said it's great
it's [__] great they got great stuff
on it I'm telling you right now go to
on.com right now and start you for the
New Year resolution you're going to
[__] love him also uh H sigs five for
how much 50 yes sir $10 a piece they're
that cheap now they used to be 20 a
piece they're five a piece go to hs.com
look at the great selection of hys sigs
that they have they have different
styles for smoking uh not Styles but
different levels like 24 milligram 16 8
and zero and they've also got a great
cigar you can take to a casino and smoke
it or you're playing black chick
whatever the [__] you do anyway uh I
like to thank meundies.com the code is
at Joy's Church on it.com and I want to
thank H sigs what's the code Joey's
Church Joey's church and get 50% off Hy
sigs and that's it man uh like I said
I'll be periscoping uh Christmas Eve and
Christmas Lee coming over Christmas day
so we'll smoke a joint and Periscope
with you and beside that from the church
family we love you all man cleia all you
[__] I love you with all my
heart and I'm happy what you do for me
talking Le who's the main man if you
need a [__] uh a Uber in Vegas before
the 31st of New Year's hit me up on
Twitter and I'll send you Larry's
[__] info for Uber and we'll get you
a good taking care of uber if you're
going to Vegas in the next 10 days days
all right M and that's it Merry
Christmas I love you guys with all my
heart thank you very much I'm at the
Hong Kong in tonight inventure if you
want to come on up tonight 8:00 show
they got great pork fried rice another
food and that's it I love you guys with
all my heart Savage dad tour starts
January 28th in Charlotte North Carolina
what what [__] I love you guys have a
merry Christmas we'll be back next week
or maybe Sunday night we don't know AR's
in town we might be doing an acid
podcast soon so strap on your
[__] seat belts again Merry
Christmas to all your families love you
thank you there goes